[拍手]
[音楽]
いいかいいろんな問題を知っていろんな
ことを感じいろんなことを考えることが
できたのなら
それはあなたの優しさです
私の両親はともに市の職員でし
た小さな頃から
行政が
身近にあったと思います
願えば
叶う
動けば変わる」を間近で見ていたように
思います
当時
掛川市の市長だった
新村
純一さんは
掛川に新幹線の駅を作るため
何度も何度も国鉄に足を運んだそうです
そのたびに冷たい対応をされ
同行をしていた職員はよく
愚痴をこぼしていたそうです
ですがそのたびに
新村市長は笑いながらこう言いました
君たちは地平線を見て仕事をしているん
じゃないか
ぼくは
北極星を見て仕事をしていると
私は31歳の時
母になりました
2008年に長男
その後長女次男を出産し今は3人の
子どもを
育てています
子供がまだ小さかった頃
毎日のように公園に
遊びに行きました
砂場で近所のママたちと
丸くなって話すのは
今日の
夕飯のメニューどうする
毎日夜泣きが辛くて寝不足だよ
そして
二人目の赤ちゃん考えてる
3人目はどうする
そういう話でした
周りのママたちは
みんなうちは
経済的に厳しいから子供は大好きだけど3
人目は難しい
子供が1歳になったらすぐ保育園に入れて
働かなくちゃいけない
そういった声をよく聞きました
私はその声を聞くたびに
胸が
ギュッと痛くなりました
なぜなら私は一人目の子どもを出産する
までとても苦労をしずっと
病院に通っていたからです
私のように
産みたいけどなかなか
埋めない人がいる一方
まだ若く
健康で子供も大好きなママたちが
埋めるけど
産めないそんな現状がとても
切なかったのです
この町なら
産みたい
この町なら安心して子供を育てられる
そういう街になったらいいなと思っていた
のが
2013年の
春のことです
その時すでに
我が家には子供が3人いました
サイズアウトした子供服
もう使わなくなったベビーカーベビー
ベッド
たくさんのおもちゃ
なかなか
捨てられず大事にとってありました
もしこのたくさんの
子どもたちのものを次のお母さん次の
赤ちゃんにお譲りすることができて
その
譲ったことで
経済的に少しでも楽になり次の
子どもを考えるきっかけになるんだったら
と思い
自宅のリビングを開放し
ぶつぶつ交換会を始めました
はじめはご近所のママたち13人がお客様
今ではその活動が10年になり
延べ220回の会を開催し
10万枚の子ども服200台のベビーカー
が次のご家族にバトンされていきました
行政や大きな
企業でしたらできることはもちろん
たくさんあると思います
でも私は
個人で小さな力だとしても
動かないより何か変わると思っています
もちろんいいことばかりではなくこの10
年いろんなことを言われました
この
少子化の時代にお古をおすすめするとは
何事かただでさえ子供用品が売れないのに
個人商店を潰す気ですか
お金にならないことをやって何の意味が
あるんですか
そう今も言われます
ですが本当にそうでしょうか
経済の天秤にかけて
反対側に乗っているのは何だと思いますか
子どもたちの未来私たちの未来です
日本はとても
恵まれた
豊かな国だと言われます
ですが赤ちゃんがどんどん減っているこの
国は本当に
豊かでしょうか
私は
子どもたちに
もったいないよ物は大切にしよう
みんなで譲り合おう
そういう言葉をかけて
子育てをしていきたいと思っています
動けば変わる
願えば
叶う
それは私が小さい頃から両親を見ていて
感じたことです
皆さんも今日何かを感じ何かを考え
動いて
いただけることができるなら私はそれを皆
さんの優しさだと思っています
いいかい
いろんなことを感じ
いろんなことを考えることができたなら
それはあなたの優しさです
だって知ることが愛の始まりだと思うから
ありがとうございます
[拍手]